what we're going to do in this video is
come up with a more rigorous definition
for continuity and the general idea of
continuity we've got an intuitive idea
of the past is that a function is
continuous at a point is if you can draw
the graph of that function at that point
without picking up your pencil so what
do we mean by that and this is a very
this what I just said is not that
rigorous or not rigorous at all is that
well let's think about the point right
over here let's say that's our C if I
can draw the graph at that point the
value of the function at the point
without picking up my pencil or my pen
that it's continuous there so I could
just start here and I don't have to pick
up my pencil and there you go I can draw
I can go through that point so we could
say that our function is continuous
there but if I had a function that
looked somewhat different than that if I
had a function that looked like this
let's say that it is defined up until
then and then there's a bit of a jump
and then it goes like this well this
would be very hard to draw with at this
would be this function would be very
hard to draw going through x equals c
without picking up my pen let's see my
pen is touching the screen touching the
screen touching the screen how do I keep
drawing this function without picking up
my pen I would have to pick it up and
then move back down here and so that is
an intuitive sense that we are not
continuous in this case right over here
but let's actually come up with a formal
definition for continuity and then see
if it feels intuitive for us so the
formal definition of continuity let's
start here we'll start with continuity
at a point so we could say the function
f is continuous continuous at x equals C
if and only if I draw this two-way arrow
so if and only if the two-sided limit of
f of X as X approaches C is equal to f
of C so this seems very technical but
let's just think about what it's saying
it's saying look if the limit as we
approach C from the left and the right
of f of X if that's actually the value
of our function there then we are
continuous at that point so let's look
at three examples let's look at one
example we are we're by our picking up
the pencil idea it feels like we are
continuous at a point and then let's
think about a couple of examples where
it doesn't seem like we're continuous at
a point and see how this more rigorous
definition applies so let's say that my
function so let's say this right over
here is y is equal to f of X and we care
about the behavior right over here when
X is equal to C this is my x-axis that's
my y-axis so we care about the behavior
when X is equal to C and so notice from
our first intuitive sense
I can definitely draw this function as
we go through x equals C without picking
up my pencil so it feels continuous
there there's no jumps or
discontinuities that we can tell it just
kind of keeps on going it seems all
connected is one way to think about it
but let's think about this definition
well the limit as X approaches C from
the left it is as we approach from the
left it looks like it is approaching it
looks like it is approaching f of C so
this is the value F of f of C right over
here and as we approach from the right
as we approach from the right it also
looks like it's approaching F of C and
we are defined right at x equals C and
it is the value that we are approaching
from both the left or the right so this
seems good in this scenario so now let's
look at some scenarios that we would
have to pick up the pencil as we draw
the function through that point through
that through that when that when X is
equal to C so let's look at a scenario
let's look at a scenario where we have
what's often called a point
discontinuity although you don't have to
know at this point
intended the formal terminology for it
so let's say we have a function that
let's see this is C and let's say our
function looks something something like
this so we go like this and at C let's
say it's equal to that so f of C is
right over here
F of C would be that value but what's
the limit as X approaches C so the limit
as X approaches C and this would be a
two-sided limit of f of X well this is
as we approach from the left it looks
like we are approaching this value right
over here and from the right it looks
like we are approaching that same value
and so we could call that L and L is
different than f of C and so in this
case by our formal definition we will
not be continuous at for F will not be
continuous for X is equal at the point X
or when X is equal to C and you can see
that there if we tried to draw this okay
my pencil is touching the paper touching
the paper touching the paper oh if I
needed to keep drawing this function I'd
have to pick up my pencil move it over
here then pick it up again and then jump
right back down and but this rigorous
definition is giving us the same
conclusion the limit as we approach X
equal C from the left and the right it's
a different value than f of C and so
this is not continuous not not
continuous and let's think about another
scenario let's think about a scenario
and actually maybe you'll see one
scenario where the limit the two sided
limit doesn't even exist so there my
AXYZ x and y and let's say it's doing
something like this let's it's doing
something like this and then it does
something like this and goes like that
and let's say that this right over here
is our C and so let's see this this is f
of C right over here
that is we've got a little bit neater
that is FOC and it does look like the
limit as X approaches C from the left so
from values less than C it does look
like that is approaching F of C but if
we look at the limit as X approaches C
from the right that looks like it's
approaching some other value that looks
like it's approaching this value right
over here let's call it al that's
approaching L and L does not equal f of
C and so in this situation the two-sided
limit doesn't even exist we're
approaching two different values when we
approach from the left and from the
right and since so the limit doesn't
even exist at C this is definitely not
going to be continuous and this matches
up to our expectations with our little
do we have to pick up the pencil test if
I have to draw this I can leave my
pencil it's on the paper it's on the
paper it's on the paper it's on the
paper how am I going to continue to draw
this function this graph of the function
without picking up my pencil pick it up
put it back down and then keep drawing
it so once again this right over here is
not continuous both intuitively by our
pick up the pencil definition and also
by this more rigorous definition where
in this case the limit the two-sided
limit at x equals C doesn't even exist
so we're definitely not be continuous
but even when the two-sided limit does
exist but the limit is a different value
than the value of the function that will
also not be continuous the only
situation that is going to be continuous
is if the two-sided limit approaches the
same value as the value of the function
and if that's true then we're continuous
if we're continuous that is going to be
true